what up guys welcome to the just curly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be learning about the wall yup the
wall
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos
um pull the footage
it's a little loud you can turn it down
a little bit a little bit oh no it's
okay
when you look at Women's uh window of
opportunity when are women at their
sexual market value Peak I've always
made the jerk you know they call the
store should we photograph right now uh
if you have it I don't know if I have
that I didn't know if I gave him the
graph but it's off of you might have it
somewhere sexual market value Graphics I
don't know if I I have it in there but
it's uh it's the um no it's not it's not
the ones that I I sent you Chris it's
the uh it's off I can go grab it I'll go
grab it here in a second don't worry
I'll get it it's my Infamous it's my
Infamous graphic with the blue and the
pink you know bell curves and remember
that was a very unscientific graph but
it was it's it's funny how accurate it
was in hindsight and I made that back in
like 2013 2014. uh Peak marketability
for women is based on how attractive she
is remember we said um uh sexual market
value is pain is is based on her agency
and that agency is tied to how
attractive she is to to the member of
the opposite seats that's why women take
their clothes off no
no why God why sorry
in a protest and they want that that uh
attention that attention because I
actually never did understand that
though uh you know I got I got jokes but
actually you know when they would do
like the walks I was like ladies
what are we doing here this is crazy
this could not be me nope that's what
gets them attention even the lizard
brain figures that out at a very early
age okay so what what you have is you've
got women between like right around 23
is where I Peg women's sexual market
value Peak years okay yeah there it is I
I won't even lie to you I think I was
hotter at 19. I feel like
damn it the future is grim guys Futures
Grim Helen Helen look at this you don't
have to be on camera but come here look
at this this is our future come here
come here you see that so you're what
are you 22 Yeah so see you you're at the
top you see that pink box
um now can you put Point
um and you see where it goes lower yeah
that's at 30. see you see that so I'm
gone I'm on the downhill decline yeah
yeah 26 but but it gets worse yeah it
just gets worse do you see that because
that's how much men will like want us
yeah yeah it's over yeah so tread
lightly you know the infamous graph
let's expand that a little bit quicker
so at the top of that at the top of the
pink bell curve right there you see that
I I hit that at about uh 23 is the time
that's true though I mean let's just
let's let's just call somebody to Spade
ladies women are hotter younger you know
like can we just can we can we get rid
of the JLo exception exception I'm so
tired of hearing about JLo ladies we're
not JLo I'm not JLo you're not JLo
nobody in here is JLo so this whole oh
well you can look good when eighty
percent of y'all are overweight no no 70
of you are overweight and you're in your
20s it's like right there and that is
where where women are at the peak of
their agency that's when guys want to
get with them the most in fact we can
look at the stats from uh well the book
called dataquilism I believe it was and
it's a list of stats that was aggregated
by uh I think it was okay Cupid the
owners of OkCupid okay so we now have
like access to data where we can we can
figure these things out right and one of
the things they figured out is that
women like right around 22 23 24 years
old are what men report across the board
from age 15 all the way to 105. say that
that is the age that they find women the
most attractive that's when they want to
bang those chicks right 22 23 24. that's
the chick for me when it comes to women
it staggers so when a woman is say like
20 years old she's looking for a guy
who's about 23 years old or 25 years old
somewhere around there and if she's 25
she's looking for a guy who's 28 years
old or just a slightly older maybe and
and statistically speaking women look
for guys who are anywhere between three
to seven years older than they are
depending on how old a woman is okay
that's true it's actually 100 true
although this new stat I learned today
might make me they said if a dude hasn't
been married by 35 to like 40 what did
it say in the last video yeah he only
has a 15 chance of getting married I was
like day maybe I should look a little
younger then
it's like 15 I don't like those odds
so that's again this is from the book
data closing and so from for women it's
the Staggering as a woman gets older
she's looking for a guy who's still
older but of around the same so 33 where
do you like your women 22 is that your
ideal 25. he says 25 to 30. but would
you agree they look better at 22 Yeah
okay six year old 37 year old guy right
that's basically how it goes they report
that's the guy that they want to get
with now we'll get to the Pareto
Principle here in a second but I wanted
to point this out because if you look at
the timeline on the age right there
from the age of 18 and I've never said
this on this show before from the ages
of 18 to 28 years old right before the
Epiphany phase that 10-year span for
women is a crucial time in a woman's
life that is when she is most able to to
optimize the alpha side of
hypergamy that's when she can get the
hottest guys as we know because that's
when guys report that this is what we
want at this and cross the board right
I'm 45 years old I want a 23 year old 50
years old 70 years old I want the 23
year old 15 years old I want the 20.
she's the strongest negotiating position
to optimize her she has her her agency
her power her ability to control her own
life or get the things that she wants
according to her sexual agency that's
when she's at her Peak within and I I
will even give it give you this between
18 and 28 years old 10 years how old do
you think a average woman's lifespan is
90 years old yeah something like that
isn't it that old 90. I thought it was
like eight I thought it was like 75 no
Soldier I don't know it would be 80. I
hope not maybe I will maybe I will so
out of 90 years on planet Earth 10 of
those years is when she's going to be
able to be at her Peak and that's what
she's going to be able to to focus on
during those those 10 years everything
past that from 28 all the way till she's
in the grave all of that is spent on the
beta bucks side of things that's where
she's looking for long-term security or
if she's not it's still in the back of
the head yeah and that's why women
obsess and that's why every chick that
comes on here is I make my own damn
money what do I bring to the table I got
my own career I got this and every time
you ask them what do you bring to the
table it's always as that the value that
they think they have is based on how
well they can satisfy long-term security
I got I got my own money I got my own
business I'm gonna freeze my eggs I can
go to the sperm bank have a baby anytime
I want I it's anything that is
complementary to long-term security
women today don't think that they are
going to ever get get long-term security
from men I put this up as a as a post
that's so true because women will always
talk about having a backup plan a
comment one time when I don't know if it
was last night or was the night before
but women when they are looking for a
guy they have they don't expect to find
long-term Security in that guy because
they think men are either abusive or
they're ridiculous or they're
incompetent and so as a result of
teaching them this for a long time they
think they have to create their own
long-term security yeah because the like
the programming has been that you cannot
rely on men for the last 50 years and
that's what they tell that's what they
tell us in the media that's what they
tell us in the messaging that you cannot
rely on men and men are stupid men are
weak men are incompetent that's why it's
I make my own damn money I'll do what I
want I guess I'm going to be alone for
the rest of my life right well if that's
the case then it behooves you to get a
degree to forget about marriage right
because these got none of these guys
will ever measure up or even if they did
measure up they'd only be good for for
Alpha and and they'll never be
good for beta bucks because I don't want
to get with a beta I don't want to get
with the chump if I don't have to they
don't have to get with the chump anymore
you know so so now it's that long-term
security aspect that is going to stick
with them for the next let's say 80
years rather than the 10 years that they
have that window to capitalize on the
alpha side of things so you have
to take that into consideration so when
you're dealing with it like if you're
down here like macking on girls or
whatever like that and that girl's
between 18 and 28 years old her
priorities are going to be much
different than the girl who's 29 to 31
years old and and so on and so forth and
they're not looking for they're not
looking forward towards the long-term
security because they don't expect to
ever find it
oh you know what's interesting I've
listened to this before I know I have
but I just listened to it in like a
complete it's so weird how you can watch
a video and like it's ever happened to
you and you hear it in a different way
and so we've been told that men will
never provide long-term security which
is why we don't look for it and that's
why we do it ourselves elves and that's
why we focus on the the alpha fox you
know that's so interesting because our
guys are ridiculous they're stupid I
don't want to have anything to do with
guys I guess I'm going to be lonely for
the rest of my life I guess you are
because you say you'll say I don't need
men you you literally don't need men and
men who don't women who don't need men
men don't need those women because they
want to be needed we need a purpose
right so anyways that's the that's the
the new kind of thing I've been thinking
about with respect to hypergamy is
there's there's how at what age and what
era and what stage of a woman's maturity
can she maximize the alpha side and
what's the rest of her life right and
and she has a lot longer to wait and a
lot longer to depend on with long-term
security than she does alpha and
that's why when women come on the show
and they're 34 or 38 years old or
whatever and they're like you know
crying or Kevin Samuel says you know
you're you're average at best that
girl's crying in her beer because she
knows that her her that 18 to 28 year
old window is gone it's long gone but
she should have been using that window
to to get long-term security rather than
just yeah
I can bang and get the get the seed
instead of the need yeah and so we
talked about how oh that's so
interesting because that's why I've
heard this before but some of the stuff
I just kind of need to be refreshed on
um but that's why women get the kid from
like the alpha fox guy because they're
told they have to take care of the kid
anyway so they don't care about
long-term security wow that's so
interesting
um guys you should subscribe to Rolo
tomasi's Channel um he is actually
really smart he's come up with a lot of
the ideas that we talk about in the
space
um yeah but this is actually that was so
interesting
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments um like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time